you
hello everyone how's everybody doing
today we have an exciting topic geometry
yeah
geometry is not the most exciting of
subjects some people say bill don't you
have anything a little more vibrational
vibrating or energetic and geometry well
you know you got to remember that
geometry serves as a bridge between
mathematics and physics so it's a base
you really got a cover and there's
nothing wrong with you know dotting all
the eyes and crossing all the t's to
make sure you covered every base and
everything is marching smoothly
you know the keep in mind that the
mathematicians they claim that
mathematics is the language of physics
and it's geometry where we have that
Ridge from mathematics into physics
historically that's how it came about
before I continue with the exciting
subject of geometry let me let me just
remind you we have a conference seventh
rational physics conference in borås
Sweden it's gonna be on the 8th of June
and I'd like to remind people constantly
so that they know about it and he can
make plans and maybe participate the
person who goes there will for sure find
a lot of a lot of group of people that
they can discuss physics riddle physics
with people who are very well versed in
the rope model and you know you can
exchange ideas and you will definitely
be challenged on your ideas or
so it's uh it's good to get together you
know front of a couple of beers and and
really hash things out anyway is uh one
of the things that people tell me you
know when they discovered the Rope model
they say it's uh it's a good
contribution to physics because it
allows them to go in there and at least
prepare you know the Rope model that now
they heard for the first time against
you know what the establishment has out
there and yeah they tell me they like
that fact alone that alone is worth for
them you know to get familiarized with
the Rope model and you know but if you
ask me that's not the main contribution
to physics that I've made I consider
that maybe a second second place
contribution I think the main
contribution is having discovered the
definition of the word object and not
only that but in tandem with it what
goes together with that is the
realization that not only you can't do
physics without objects but that you
know you you need to define this word
and it's very important for the purposes
of physics it all goes together as a
package and I think that's the main
contribution and it also leads us to us
you know a related issue which is that
I'm proposing a new version of the
scientific method I'm saying some
science is something else from what the
mathematical physicists are doing and
you know that has to that has to make
you think you know should we go with
authority should we go with tradition or
should we analyze this objectively and
okay what is what is physics about what
is science about and I'm saying that
what these people have been doing I say
for the last 400 years but that's not
totally true because I think that people
like Newton and you know a lot of people
that came in the 18th and 19th century
Faraday James Maxwell from hell
they were trying to really figure out
how this universe works they were trying
to figure out how light works when they
discovered all trizzie how electricity
how magnets were how gravity works they
really want to get to the bottom of
these things and eventually you know
they came up with the idea of atoms they
want to know how atoms behaved as well
what they looked like that kind of thing
that all stopped in the 20th century
about a hundred years ago in the 1920s
until that time people still had an
interest in knowing how the universe
works by how I don't mean a description
I mean the why I mean how in the sense
of what is the mechanism that whether
you make nature users they were
interested in that and for that you need
to identify the objects the invisible
objects and what came after that is
something totally different
it's they went on the path of math
equations descriptions measurement
predictions observation gawking what I
call you know just observe and they
observe something that is visible and
they have to infer what is invisible and
their inferences were wrong or
irrational but they continued and and
I'm saying no no that is physics none of
that is science science is something
else science is trying to figure out the
mechanisms and you could make a case and
I think a very good case that up until
at least the end of the 19th century
people were interested in finding out
you know what causes things they were
interested in mechanisms they were
interested in identifying the invisible
entities
mother nature use us to like I say run
her shop and yeah I think that's that's
what really science is about that's what
physics is about and that's what I call
science and physics and that's what I do
and of course the mathematicians have no
idea what I'm talking about because they
say no no you know physics is math but
physics is this equation this
description and you know I'm saying no
it's an explanation it's not a
quantitative description it's a rational
explanation
give me a rational explanation for what
how light does her magic how gravity
does it's magic how magnet or how
electricity do their magic that's
physics and so so I'm proposing that you
know even though we intuitively may have
had this idea I'm formalizing you know
I'm saying science is about that and not
about what the mathema to mathematicians
do you know what the mathematical
physicists do we have to separate those
two and the question is how did we
arrive with mathematical physics and the
answer to that is that what's served as
a bridge was this discipline known as
geometry geometry is see if you just do
pure math you know you're really not
doing physics you you have to somehow
get in touch with objects with figures
they're not not numbers figures I mean
you know geometric figures and so it's
geometry that really serves as the
bridge into physics and so it's worth it
to look at and find out if geometry you
know standing on solid foundations
I mean if geometry is standing on
quicksand think think about it building
you build it on a quick set what happens
when it falls apart
and so there's nothing wrong with
checking a CEO of geometry you really
covered all the bases dotted all the
eyes crossed all the t's and no it's on
sound footing so what is geometry well
here I have a definition and I brought
about last week and it goes something
like this it says that geometry is a
branch of mathematics that deals with
shapes and sizes okay so that's what it
deals with primarily in other words it
goes into relations and all that but
primarily you know it deals with shapes
and sizes and continues in saying and
this is by the way from one site but
pretty much all sites say the same thing
geometry building blocks include
undefined terms now that's a lousy way
to start the discipline you say it's
about shapes and sizes and then it says
you know we're gonna start by saying
that we can't define the especially the
most fundamental terms and they say some
concepts central to geometry are not
defined in terms of simpler concepts the
most familiar of these undefined terms
are point line and plane
oh my god it turns out we're gonna be
doing geometry we're going to be doing
solids we're going to be doing planes
and all those are made by points
possibly even by lines and it turns out
that we don't have a definition for a
point line or even the plane that's
interesting and that's more than
interesting it's antenna mates should
raise a red flag and it makes you kind
of think you know are these people on a
sound footing and you know they try to
define the point and they just say we're
knob jekt is is leads to the idea of an
exact fixed location so a point
apparently is a fixed location but then
they continues give an example say a dot
on a sheet of paper such things are
called representations of points that's
interesting because you know a dot in a
location are totally you know
compatible one has nothing to do with
the other a dot is a geometric figure in
a location as an abstract concept it's
got to do with place give you save in
position so the question is of course if
you're trying to blend the concepts such
as location with a physical object such
as a dot yeah you're gonna have trouble
defining that term and maybe that's
where the problem is with the line we
have the same issue that you find as a
row of points extended infinitely in
both directions infinitely big problem
extended already a problem points it
relies on points
I thought we couldn't define a point so
now we're what are we referring to is is
that point are we supposed to put the
word dot in there or the word location
so okay we say these guys you know
they're they're not professionals where
did they get all this stuff and you know
when you look at throughout history you
end up with mr. Euclid he's the guy who
set up all these definitions or notions
or axioms laws rules foundations for
geometry already in the days of the
Greeks let's see what you it has to say
about it and this is mr. Euclid he says
he wrote his book elements and been
translated here what you're looking at
is the main 1661 version of elements and
he starts out with three definitions
these two of them what a point is that's
that which has no part what is a line a
line is breathless length okay not very
not very precise in his definitions that
which has no part has been interpreted
as that which has no shape no size no
dimensions and then we have a line what
is a line its breathless length what do
you mean it's length you mean a line is
a length you know length is an abstract
concept
I thought we were talking about geometry
and geometry dealt with shapes and sizes
primarily shanks I mean if you don't
have a shape forget about size right so
you need a shape and neither one of
these two neither the point that you
could define nor the deafen the line
definition deal with shapes and it's
interesting and if you go down to
definition 13 and 14 you'll find that
14s has a figure is that which is
contained by any boundary or boundaries
but then you go to 13 where it goes to
the boundary it says is that which is
the extremity of anything so we got a
circular set of definitions you know a
figure is that which has a perimeter and
what is a perimeter is that where a
figure ends it's the fence were uh
figure ends so we don't have a
definition of what a figure is or what
essentially what a shape is what an
object is and and of course he didn't
apply those two to the point or the line
because he's he's using concepts to
define point and line so Euclid did not
have a good grasp of definitions of
scientific definitions and that was our
starting point okay so we started off on
the wrong foot that's that was 2,000
years ago obviously we must have made
significant progress since then right
okay that's fine now well let's go see
dr. math he Amos not what this what
points and minds and geometry are all
about
so dr. math he writes a book no known as
introduction or introduces geometry it's
an introduction to geometry right okay
so what are these points lines what is
geometry about in general so he says
points lines and planes correspond to
talking about no dimensions one
dimension in two dimensions in the
coordinate plane okay so he relates
these three words point lines and planes
to dimensions a line is one-dimensional
since one number since one number the
distance from zero tells you where you
our okay so that's a line where you are
a plane is two-dimensional since you
need X&Y to locate a point okay what's
that got to do with what a plane is and
then a point is dimensionless again none
of those three definitions have anything
to do with physics or even with geometry
they're talking about concepts if
geometry is about shapes as a minimum
you would think that you know you could
you could define what a point is what a
line is what a [ __ ] what a plane is and
these guys are saying and you know
they're just giving you a mathematical
description they say you know a line
requires one number so what and a plane
requires two numbers to locate a point
within it and what is a point well
Steinman you don't need any lines to or
any points or any numbers to designate a
point and it gives you the he says
following that says it consists of only
location that's what a point does right
consists of only location so it's only
possible to be one place if you're on a
point if you're at a point you don't
need any extra numbers to tell you where
you are points lines and planes are
foundations of the whole system of
geometry oh good big big big words there
but then he says but point line and
plane are all undefined terms how can
that be and here's the explanation well
any definition we could give them would
depend on the definition of some other
mathematical idea that these three terms
help define in other words the
definition would be circular that's
essentially the worldly wisdom today
across the board that's what all these
people believe in they they or how they
explain it they say you know we can't
define these terms because we would need
more words and those who would have to
be defined and since these are the
foundations of everything else that's
like you the buck stops there that's the
bottom line okay so not much progress
from mr. math
from from the days of Euclid we're still
suffering for definitions okay let's see
if we go to a more respectable site more
authoritative site okay let's go to
Wolfram they're there they they pride
themselves and saying you see it in
their title says the web's most
extensive mathematics resource oh my god
and it says built on mathematic tech not
mathematical technology okay whatever
that is okay so so here we have a
respectable source what do they say
about geometry well they say yes again
it's the study of figures in a space of
a given number of dimensions and of a
given type and that definition is more
or less corroborated by the wikipedia
says geometry is a branch of mathematics
concerned with questions of shape size
relative positions of figures and the
properties of space and you can see they
use that in these works figures in space
so we just need to find out what what
they refer to when they're using these
words what is space what is a figure and
so when we look at what is it Wolfram we
look up the word space and you know they
do have something here and they say
space the concept of of a space is an
extremely general and important
mathematical construct okay good that's
a good start
let's see what it is and I mean they
just go and continue members of the
space obeys certain addition properties
spaces which have been investigated and
found to be of interests are usually
named after one or more of their
investigators this practice
unfortunately leads to names which give
very little insight into the relevant
properties of a given space and then go
out and talk about a couple words about
Euclidean minkovski and
biological spaces never once does
Wolfram define what a space is and they
give all these examples of all the
spaces who you know all these name
spaces that they just mentioned but they
never define what a space is so we don't
know what a space is let's see if the
Wikipedia can do any better and the
wikipedia says okay it says space okay
in mathematics these spaces are set
uh-huh
sometimes called the universe with some
added structure okay so we have a set
and structure what is a set
well they continue to say a space
consists of selected mathematical
objects oh my god what could a
mathematical object be I know what an
object is but I don't know what a
mathematical object is so let's find out
what all these words mean space is a set
let's see in mathematics a set is a
collection of distinct objects okay
considered as an object in its own right
for example the number two the numbers 2
4 & 6 are distinct objects these are
objects a 2 is an object wow I don't
know I don't know about that I know a
table is an object I know a dog is an
object know that 3 is an object but I
never knew number 2 is an object I
thought number 2 was a concept and in
fact they say the concept of a set is
one of the most fundamental in
mathematics ok so it's one of the most
fundamental and they say that it's a
collection collection of objects and the
objects are numbers so what have we
learned
ok so let's see if we can find out what
a mathematical object is again it's an
abstract object that's what a
mathematical object is ok what is an
abstract object well it has no physical
reference whereas a concrete objects do
we still don't know what an object is
all we know that it's got no physical
it's nothing physical
ok and says they are most commonly used
in philosophy and semantics so we got a
problem here because
people say that mathematics is the
language of physics and what are they
talk about they talk about abstractions
and they say that these have to do
primarily with philosophy and semantics
then they accuse me of doing semantics
it turns out that these people are doing
semantics and they call it doing physics
because they say that mathematics is the
language of physics so we got a problem
and again we're talking about you know
how they're applying all this to
geometry which is the the physical
bridge to physics okay so keep that in
mind okay that's in the background here
okay what is a structure they had the
word structure they're added structure
general definition of structure proposed
by Bourbaki
embraces all common types of spaces
provides a general definition of
isomorphism and justifies the transfer
of properties between isomorphic
structures so what is a the definition
of structure well it's a transfer of
properties between structures great so
what have we learned we haven't learned
much but I like the last line because
that one puts everything in perspective
while modern mathematics uses many types
of spaces such as la la la la la it does
not define the notion of space itself so
now we know what a space is space is
that which has never been defined so so
we have Wolfram and Wolfram says you
know talks about spaces that's what they
do I guess for a living and they don't
define it they just name different they
have all these different kinds of spaces
in Coffs be space and Euclidian space
and all these named spaces but they
don't know what a space it is because
they can't define that they haven't
defined it okay have they defined the
word figure another important word
because if physics deals with shapes and
figures right some kind of things and
some object right what is a figure well
you saw that euclid could define it he
said you know figure is what ends in a
perimeter and what is the perimeter is
what
whatever it is ending there so he's got
a circular definition but hopefully you
know after two thousand years Wolfram to
do a little better in here it is they
say they don't have a definition for
figure but they say oh but we we have
found impossible figures it's in a class
of illusion within which an object which
is physically unrealizable is apparently
depicted okay we still don't know what I
figure it is but they're already talking
about it and it goes through what an
illusion is it's an illusion is an
object or drawing which appears to have
properties which are physically
impossible deceptive or counterintuitive
so they never define the word figure
they just start using it they do have
the word object but when you look it up
it says a mathematical structure and
again we don't know what a structure is
because they've never defined that word
very well and it's a mathematical
structure in a category great I have
what have we learned you know here we
have the word structure and Wikipedia
says the structure on a set is an
additional mathematical object that in
some manner attaches to that set to
endow it with some additional meaning or
significance well so far all we have is
no significance no meaning we don't
understand squat we haven't learned
anything these people have circular
arguments
no wonder they can't define any word
because they never learn how to find
words scientifically and people
sometimes accuse me and they say well
I'll bill you you play a lot of semantic
games and you know a we want to do
physic we don't want it to grammar see
the first the first thing you should
realize is all these people from Euclid
onwards they tried to formalize they try
to define the foundations of geometry
that's why they took the trouble to
write all this stuff because if
definitions are not important they could
have continued say well we're not going
to define any time we're just gonna run
with our intuitions did it do that they
sat down and they try to define words
were just not successful that's the
problem they were not successful but
they claimed later on you know
sweeping statement saying that
mathematics is the language of physics
and they can't even define their their
own language of mathematics they're
telling you that in so many words in
your face they're saying we don't know
what a point is we don't know what a
line is we don't know what a space is we
don't know what a figure is but let's
continue so why did they take the
trouble in the first place then the
other issue is that you do need to
establish the foundations of a
discipline because you need to establish
what it what is the you know what are
the limits of the discipline you you
have to find out you know what it you
know are we gonna include medicine
within physics or within geometry
medicine I think is outside the bounds
of the geometry right I would think and
so you know you have to define the
limits of the different disciplines for
this you need words so you need to
define certain terms you need to
establish the foundations and again I
got a problem with these people because
you know I have different foundations
I'm saying that you know my number one
contribution to science was not really
the rope that's my second contribution
my first one was the definition of the
word object you need to know what an
object is for the purposes of physics
and what this does is also established
that physics is something else than what
we've been doing in the last hundred
years physics has to do with objects not
with math and these people say that they
have a different in my golden principle
says you can't do physics without an
object you know physics requires an
object and they're saying something else
they're saying you can't do physics
without math you need bath then maybe
you need predictions and maybe you need
experiments and you need verification
and observation and you know equations
of measurement and I'm saying we don't
need any of that
we need rational explanations so there
is a difference in foundation I'm saying
we need physics has to do with rational
explanations of mechanisms these people
are saying no physics is description
mathematical descriptions
and so what you should ask yourself is
if physics is just mathematical
descriptions aren't me interested or
within fishes don't we study you know
aren't me interested in finding out how
a magnet attracts another I don't be
interested in figuring out you know why
a spoon falls to the floor not to the
ceiling are those issues of physics are
those questions of physics subjects
matter of physics if they are the
mathematicians will never never you know
pinpoint that will never figure them out
because they're doing something else
they're doing oh no we measured and we
create an equation to describe the
measurement you know what happened and
that's physics and what's the physical
interpretation oh we think it's done by
angels or you know particles are doing
this or they can tell you whatever
because they say well that's not physics
anyway that's Impala gee that's
philosophy that's metaphysics physics is
the mathematical description we're done
with you we already measured we we gave
you the equation what else do you want
and so we got a problem
because I'm saying that you know up till
the 19th century people were interested
in finding out the mechanisms what the
invisible entities were and that stopped
from 1920s onwards okay and so we have a
difference in there in foundation I'm
saying that I'm that's my contribution
I'm saying every embedded physics you
could say or brought back you could say
classical physics and say look but these
guys were trying to do that was physics
they were trying to figure out how this
universe works I thought that was what
physics was all about trying to figure
out you know how it worked and by how I
mean why what causes it to work and you
can't figure that out with math mantis
tells you how another kind of how tells
you just a description saying yeah the
earth goes around the Sun and it goes so
fast in so many minutes and so many
years you know they just described and
if you want an explanation for how you
know
what what is causing that to happen what
causes gravity would cause his light
what causes magnetism they say oh you're
doing ontology or you're doing benefit
that's not part of physics and that's
that's where we have a problem because
if we have no explanations for some of
these phenomenon today is because we're
doing math and not physics and it's
geometry that took us there so so we do
need to find out what geometry is about
you can see that these people haven't
defined the terms the foundations of fit
of geometry so so they they built this
castle on quicksand and you say well how
can that be we've been doing geometry
from 2,000 years and you're saying that
it's not a solid foundation all the
axioms all these angles and you know
volumes and areas and so on that they
calculated all that's worthless well I'm
saying that you you know you need to
establish the foundations and I'm saying
the foundations are not there they have
defined ordered space they have defined
what a figure is they have defined what
a point is which is their bread and
butter it's their building block they
haven't you find what a line is they
they don't know what a plane has they
they say they can't define any of these
terms and you know at some point you got
to figure out you know whether what
they're doing your science has anything
to do with science I thought science had
to start with rigid rigorous definition
solid definitions because that's what
the foundations of science is if you're
just not going to go past it and say
well I I don't I'm not concerned about
that we'll let someone else do that see
see they're they're pushing all these
things the responsibility for all that
to English majors to librarians they're
saying well you know or philosophers you
know they say we do physics here well
what is the definition of a point oh you
got to go to the other side of campus
for that see the definition of point is
determined by all these librarians
English majors and philosophers they did
deal with those
definitely we just use whatever they
give us so we got a problem because
these people are talking to each other
they they're in different disciplines
it's like they're saying you know the
definition of the word point is not part
of our discipline it's not part of
geometry we don't deal with that that
that's librarians that deal with that we
just deal with using the point and what
is a point well go ask the librarian we
just borrowed whatever they do find
that's the problem
the problem is that these people are
using terms which they haven't defined
they don't know what they are but they
said we're going to use them anyways you
know what we mean you know
wink-wink nudge-nudge we know what we
mean so they want you to intuitively
understand what they're talking about
and it's very simple you know they just
can't define these things here we have
Wolfram trying to define the word point
and here again we're talking about a
authoritative soil source right these
people are authorities and they say look
a point is a zero dimensional
mathematical object whatever that means
because if it's zero that mentioned it's
not an object if it's a mathematical
object whatever that is a two or a three
or four you know again it's meaningless
what they're talking in mind obviously
they're talking about abstractions says
which can be specified in n dimensional
space using an N tuple in other words
what they're using is ordered pairs or
triplets or whatever right and so you
can see the pictures on the bottom I put
the blue images their words whatever
blue letters they're saying you know
here you have the point P on a plane and
you have a another point P on a cube and
solid and what does that point P well
they're saying it's an ordered pair or
an ordered triplet they're saying it's
an N two poles and each one of those by
the way is in their languages of
dimensions so they can have infinite
dimensions they can have all the letters
into that alphabet and then so okay so
so they're talking about the location of
the point P they designate that with
a little dot and so the question is you
know is the dot the point or is the
location of point are we talking about
the elephant that is at that location or
are we talking about the location when
we get rid of the elephant and you say
well obviously you know the point it
refers to the location oh why don't they
call it location okay why don't they
call location and not point why do they
have to call it point and designate it
with a dot if if they're talking about
locations and here you can see although
the notion of a point is intuitively
rather clear the mathematical machinery
used to deal with points and point-like
objects can be surprisingly slippery no
kiddin because they never defined you
know these words they never defined what
a point is and then you have the
definition of the word line from again
from wolfram and they say look a LAN is
a straight one dimensional figure and
they show one at the bottom which to me
looks more like a two-dimensional figure
you know the fact that I can see it
points to the fact that that we're
looking at a two-dimensional elongated
rectangle that that's what a line is I
mean objectively and it says extending
infinitely in both directions well if it
extends infinitely obviously it's not
bounded and hopefully in physics all
objects are bounded so what does this
line have to do with physics if it's if
it's still growing
if it's still extending and we can't see
the end of it so again they've got a you
know they say that mathematics is the
language of physics that geometry in a
way you know is is the is the bridge the
the language of physics and here they're
talking about stuff that has nothing to
do with physics first of all what I'm
staring at is not zero at one
dimensional yeah and neither is the
point of zero dimensional entity second
they haven't defined a word figure but
I'll take this as a figure and figure
that I'm seeing is a two time
rectangle and they're saying no it's
one-dimensional when my eyes tell me
something different so they're trying to
believe they're selling me a used car
here you know and they say it's infinite
which again has nothing to do with
physics because it means that this thing
is not bounded which is what Euclid at
least defines a figure as he says a
figure is something that ends at a
boundary and this guy has no boundary
and I put by the way the plus infinity
negative infinity R just to illustrate
the fact that this thing continues out
forever so when they finish building
their line I'll find out what it is but
it turns out that you know they're
referring to you know not a figure like
they say they're you straight
one-dimensional figure that's not what
it is it's it's what Euclid define it's
a length of distance and they're talking
about distance travel they're saying you
know this is an itinerary it's not even
a line it's not a geometric thing and so
so we got a problem here because the
question is if mathematics specifically
geometry is the language of physics but
these guys are talking about
abstractions they're not talking about
figures they're not talking about
objects then how can they claim that
geometry mathematics in general is the
language of physics we have a problem
here this is a serious problem because
these people are entering a field for
which they have not even set the
foundations in a field that by their own
bracketing by their own foundations the
ones that they want to establish not
only have they not defined the term but
it has nothing to do with physics has to
do with abstractions you know they put a
line there and you say okay a line
belongs to physics because it's a
rectangle so you can say well okay it
deals with this object is figure this
shape that I see in front of me but the
xi shape that you're seeing is not what
they call a line a line is an abstract
concept that is not really
one-dimensional it's non dimensional
what they're saying with the
one-dimensional phrase there then that
label
is that you need only one number to
designate a point on the line that's
what they're saying they're talking
about a distance again from some
arbitrary point to where you end it
that's where the line ends but turns out
that's not a line that's a line segment
the line continues infinitely and is not
even a geometric figure so all this
stuff you can see why they couldn't
define it because all this stuff is just
a big mess it's a big mess because they
never defined the bread and butter of
geometry okay
there's major problems with geometry
with the foundations of geometry and
there's major problems with in
mathematics much less can that be
considered as a foundation for physics
mathematics has nothing to do with
physics first because mathematics is
just a description but second or more
fundamental yeah is that the foundations
of geometry which is supposed to be the
bridge have never been established at
these from a physical point of view it's
all extractions the point is not a point
in other words the point is not a dot
it's a location a line is not a stake
it's an itinerary and so they take this
itinerary say oh with this itinerary
we're gonna build planes and solids no
way you don't build planes and solids
you know with with with itineraries you
can build them with stakes you need you
need bricks to build something and this
is not a brick this is 19 area this is a
vert you can't use a verb to construct
solids so so the foundations are not
there if something is terribly wrong
with the foundations of geometry and you
know it's always been like that it's
never changed these people have simply
jumped over skipped over the foundations
of the geometry it just kept going and
then extrapolated that on to physics say
oh by the way you know we we are the
foundations of physics also no way the
foundations of physics are objects and
there are no objects in geometry
they're ideal objects which again don't
exist in nature don't exist in real
physics and and that's only includes the
solids that's you only branch that fits
in with physics then the planes the
lines and the points the things that
they can't define they have nothing to
do with physics and they have nothing to
do with reality those are things that
are used for calculations they say I can
calculate an angle okay so you can
calculate an angle I'm calculating an
area okay you can calculate an area I
can calculate a bog so what what's that
got to do with busy's yeah physics has
to do with you know tell me how gravity
works you know what causes gravity
that's what physics is about and if
you're just gonna say what mathematics
is physics in just the description is
mathematical quantitative description is
equivalent to physics well yeah you'll
never answer those questions see people
ask qualitative type of questions you
know how does how does the atom work and
they say well let me show you the
distribution the probability function oh
how the how the atom is constructed and
how the electron goes around and that
kind of thing you know and these people
are talking about you know probability
functions what's that got to do with
with how the atom works and this is you
will never find out will never figure
this out as long as we continue thinking
that mathematics is the language of
physics okay so let's get down to to
what really physics is about and here
I've put you know the first golden
principle as I call it this principle is
cinah quantum you absolutely need it and
I'm saying this is my main contribution
to physics not so much the rope rope
I'll put that as number two the first
one is here
physics requires an object no 1 in
10,000 years figure that out you know
it's it's like nobody saw they say oh we
need math well don't you need objects to
do physics I mean do we need math if
there are no objects in the universe can
you do something with your math
what is your math worth if if there are
no objects if we remove all the galaxies
all the stars all the atoms all the
planets everything every gas everything
that's out there what's going on what's
happening what are you observing what
experiment can you do but see you need
objects to do physics and they never
realize that and obviously if you need
an object to do physics and that's your
first principle for physics the next
item on the on your action item list is
is that you need to define what an
object is and we define an object as
that which has shape and that's what
Euclid was referring to when he tried to
define in his clumsy way what a figure
is you know he said you know it's that
which has a perimeter and perimeter is
that which stops an object from growing
that's essentially what he said so there
was a circular definition here we're
saying it's that which has shape and
people say well bill can you tell me
what a shape is and the answer is I
don't need to because we need to define
it for physics and we just have to
select from different criteria we have
you know volume we have mass we have
that which moves that which is made of
something and we have all these things
which with which we can compare the word
shape is do we need to know exactly what
mass is do we need to know exactly what
volume is no we just need to know which
criteria to you should we work with
criterion to use in this case we're
going to compare shape against motion
against volume against mass and we got
to choose one and what we're going to
choose a shape we're not going to choose
mass because mass all the others
essentially are built on motion and
motion requires two locations of an
object that means it's like requiring
two objects what is a concept we need to
distinguish objects from concepts and
it's a word that in växjö embodies two
objects which means that you're going to
need to define the word object before
you defined the word concept that's the
first issue
the
second issue is that every word in the
dictionary can be placed under one of
these two categories it's either an
object or a concept okay and then for
all practical purposes a concept is that
which has which doesn't have shape and
the main concept involved in physics or
you could say it's not involved in
physics really because we don't need it
it's just serves as a background and
that's the word space if something is
that which has shaped nothing as the
antonym and means that which doesn't
have shape and the synonyms include
space vacuum boy etc okay so once we
defined that and you know we say okay we
know now what an object is and the next
question people have is well it's really
a concept a word that evokes or bodies
two objects is that really true I mean
you know I'd hate to test it on every
word in the dictionary there are
thousands of words in there I mean how
can we be sure of that well you know
here's one way that you can check that
out you know on your own here you have
parts of speech okay and you have
different things in there you have
different types of words and you know
you have these different categories of
words and you have articles you have
prepositions adjectives adverbs verbs
conjunctions pronouns nouns those are
the primary ones and if you read through
each one of these you'll find out that
in all cases you are essentially
identical embodying two words to two
things or two concepts in some cases but
you know again what is the concept is it
it has to do with the word to that with
a concept of to and in it's either an
object to objects or with two words
treated as objects and an article is
used to modify a noun so unique so
what's the purpose of the article is to
you need the noun so it alludes directly
or indirectly to a noun
what is a preposition again it indicates
location nearer beside her on top of
some other noun or between two nouns or
pronouns or some two things what is an
adjective it's a word that describes a
noun what is an adverb a word that
modifies what qualifies an adjective
verb adverb or workgroup etc etc so it
always refers to something else as well
verb action state are occurrence and
forming the main part of the predicate
of sentence what is an action it
involves two locations of an object so
it's like you're treating the second
location as a second object you need to
frames in the universal film to have a
verb an action conjunction and a word
used to connect clauses so again we're
talking about two pronoun same thing a
word that can be can function as a noun
phrase used by itself and that refers to
either to the participants into this
verse like I you I means that there is
you and you means that it there is I or
he or she or something or to someone or
something mentioned elsewhere in the
discourse so in all cases all these
parts of speech
you know they invoke or body are in some
way introduced or allude to a second
object or to two objects or words
treated as objects and a noun the noun
is a weird one and that's why we have to
be careful with the word noun a noun you
know for the purposes of physics okay we
got to keep this in mind for the
purposes of physics only objects can
serve as nouns we can't use the word
motion motion in ordinary speeches are
now but that word motion cannot be
introduced into physics as a noun as a
subject of a sentence as an object that
performs an action okay and you say well
when you call it an where you say now
you
redefining the word now do you need to
do that can't you just say well physics
is done with objects well there's a
problem with that the problem is that
the statements that you make in physics
if we're doing gonna do it formally
we're gonna do it right then the subject
of the sentence cannot be a verb you
cannot talk about motion you cannot talk
about orbit you cannot talk about
itinerary those are verbs the correct
way is to say Jupiter orbits Jupiter's
the noun orbits is what it does that's
the correct way now nothing wrong with
saying the orbit of Jupiter okay
nothing wrong with that except that we
need to identify which one is the noun
which one is the subject the subject is
the thing and the thing is Jupiter and
the problem is we get so used to you
using ordinary speech in a scientific
context that we forget about that and we
started talking about fields as if they
were object we talk about energy as if
it were an object or massive time all
these become objects now we've been time
now we move a mass we transfer energy
that's where the problem comes in
because now we've converted ordinary
speech we introduced that into physics
and now we forget about the fact that
these are not nouns these are not
subjects of a sentence they can't be in
physics but we treat them as such and
that's where we get confused we lose
track of what these words mean what they
really mean all these are concepts and
concepts cannot serve as the noun in a
sentence of physics that's why I use the
word noun to refer to objects only there
is a reason it's not that I just want to
change the language where the hell of it
and say well you know you're making it
more complicated and it is no it's that
a statement of physics can only have as
an object as a subject of the sentence
only can have an object as
now in a sentence the predicate the
predicate has to be you know all these
verbs and and that's where the problem
is you know they begin to talk about
waves as physical objects time is a
physical object that's where the danger
is that's where the problem is
you know they forget about where all
this came from anyways let's get down to
the conclusions here I'm saying that
geometry has no solid foundations
therefore you know it's cannot be used
in physics essentially geometers have no
definition for the key word space and
figure ok these two words have never
been defined and for sure physics deals
with figures with objects as I call them
first and foremost and the word space is
is really weird because space is nothing
it's a synonym of nothing it's a synonym
of vacuum of emptiness and they talk
about three dimensional space two
dimensional space and four dimensional
space and all these dimensions that
space has space has no dimensions and
again it's uh it's this ordinary speech
that has penetrated physics space is
treated like a physical objects they
talk about the dimensions of space no
it's the objects that have that meant
it's not space space has no dimensions
whatsoever it's non dimensional it's a
concept all concerts have no dimensions
whatsoever you can't talk about the Dyne
mentions of love not in physics
nevertheless none of the fundamental
figures with which geometers build their
discipline are defined or even qualify
as figures you know a point is not a
figure it's a location and a line is an
itinerary not a stick so these are not
figures and therefore if geometry is a
study of figures of shapes these do not
qualify as figures as geometric figures
and the point is depicted as a dot but
means location geometers claim that it
is zero D when the object we're staring
at is patently 2d you're looking at a
dot
which is as a minimum 2d maybe it's 3d
you know I imagine you had to talk to
Klingon Klingon visits us he's got a
different language and you say look this
is a point and you put a dot on the
board or on a piece of paper and he says
okay he looks at any what does he sees
he's a two-dimensional object you say
okay I know what a point is that's what
he thinks he says it's it's that little
smudge that you made on the paper it's
two dimension and then you tell oh by
the way it's zero dimensional you know
he's gonna have a contradiction in his
mind what do you mean I'm looking at
something that's two dimensional and the
line is Illustrated as an elongated 2d
box geometers tell you that you are
staring at a 1d line no way if it's a 1d
line they're talking about something
else they're talking about location
along an itinerary or they're talking
about the itinerary itself or length or
distance traveled or whatever then
that's not a geometric figure don't tell
me that that 2d box is one dimension and
geometers never realized that you don't
define objects you point to them that's
that's a major failure of geometers see
they said that we can't define the point
we can't define the line of course you
can because you don't define objects not
in rational physics what you do is you
point to them and name them if you want
the Klingon to understand what a table
is you point and you say table now he
knows where the table is you don't
define it you don't say look a chair is
something has got four legs a seed and a
backrest you know he still doesn't know
what you're talking about
but if you put say look that's a chair
okay I know what you meant by chair now
it's that thing that you pointed to over
there see and and geometers never
discover that that you don't define
geometric figures what you do is and
that's what they do they and they strain
their minds and they say how do i you
find a point how do i define the line
how do i define a plane well I can't
define it so I'll just leave it like
that I'll say that it's undefined no the
way you it's very simple you make a dot
on the board and you say that's a dot
you want to call
point fine caught a point but don't tell
me that a point is zero dimensional or
that it's a location because that's not
what I drew on the board
what is staring at me is a dot and that
is a figure if you're gonna say that the
word point means location just use the
word location don't use the word point
to confuse me okay and don't draw a
thought to confuse me and then the last
one is geometry is not in cannot serve
as a bridge between mathematics and
physics because it works with
abstractions physics deals with objects
abstractions and abstractions and
physical are antonyms so if if these
people are working with abstractions
first of all they're not working with
physics second they can't claim that
mathematics is the language of physics
and certainly geometry cannot serve as
the bridge between mathematics and
physics with that I'll see you next time
around I'll continue with lying and I'm
sorry if it's a boring subject but we
need to cover this space you know and
again one of the reasons I cover these
things is to make sure that you
understand that we're a lot of the
misconceptions that we have today in
physics so called physics mathematical
physics come from they come from the
fact that these people have taken
mathematics and extrapolated it onto
fizzing they say that's physics no that
ain't physics physics is explain to me
how gravity works explain to me how a
magnet attracts another that's physics
and if that's not physics what is it
please tell me is attraction between two
magnets how it does it is that not
subject matter of physics and if the
answer if you give to that question is
yes it is then these people will never
figure it out with math because all they
can do is describe with an equation what
is happening and then they give you
bogus you know explanation say well I
think it's done you know with particles
or waves or fields or whatever they give
you an any word in there and they say oh
we can't define it but that's how we
interpret it but anyways that's not part
of physics ontology that's philosophy of
physics physics is just
the objective description mathematical
description right and so we'll never
have an answer and we don't have any
answers to those questions today because
of that because we allow the
mathematicians to take over it's like
you know the religious people have taken
over a theism something like that okay
so we'll see you next time and we'll
continue with line so if you're not
interested in geometry now you know what
the subject matter will be next time
around I'll continue with line and
hopefully I can cover a couple other
subjects as well I'm going to be
covering planes and diamonds it will see
how much I can cover we'll see you next
time bye bye